[Music]
so now let's talk about the various
episodes or the eras of evolution of
life the first one which we have a
fossil record of is known as the aegea
current era and it existed from 630 to
542 million years ago here the life
forms that were found were mostly
aquatic and they resembled today's
jellyfishes or mollusks that we find or
even bombs but they were pretty much
primitive they were multicellular as
well as unicellular organisms could also
be found
moving on to the next era was the
cambria era and it existed from 542 to
485 million years ago and
in this particular era
organisms still were aquatic but now
they evolved
in size and also in their structures you
might notice that now they have
this particular exoskeleton which was
mainly made up of cytin and other
proteins one of the major organisms
whose fossil records are very well
preserved from the cambrian era is
known as the trilobite as i was saying
and here for the first time
we could find prey predator
relationships so we could find some
larger organisms like this one which
used to be the predator which attacked
smaller organisms and fed them
feed on them
those being the prey
the next
period which is smaller than an era is
known as the ordovician period which
existed from 485 to 445 million years
ago and yes you can see the from the
fossil records they looked somewhat
similar to a starfish
and those predators that i was talking
about
now grew further in size they evolved
some unique characteristics which again
gave them an edge over others for
example tentacles it helped them to
catch their prey more efficiently
whereas the preys also evolve certain
features which give them an edge to
survive for example they started growing
some hard shells like a snail
inside which they could now live and
stay protected from those predators
and because of these particular features
and edges life form suddenly saw a huge
boost in its quantity and there was
again a
large number of flora and fauna in this
aquatic setting
during this ordovician period
and as i told you in the preamble that
whenever there is a huge flourishment of
life and the competition rises it is
followed by a major mass extinction
event so that this was the first mass
extinction that occurred on earth and it
was believed that it happened because of
a sudden rise in oxygen level as well as
the temperatures for example the hot
areas became hotter and the cold areas
became cooler this mainly happened
because of the change of the atmospheric
composition and as plants started to
flourish more enzyme the bacterium
started to grow more the amount of
oxygen in the atmosphere started to rise
tremendously and therefore reducing the
amount of greenhouse gases that caused
the fluctuation in the temperature and
since this was the early times of oxygen
being created in the atmosphere there
was really no good amount of ozone that
would shield earth from the harmful uv
rays so those were the reasons for this
particular first mass extinction but
although it might be sad that
so many life forms died it made way for
new life forms to evolve so the
period or the era that followed this
particular mass extinction is known as
the siliorian era and it existed from
the 445 million years to 420 million
years ago
and now
this new
forms of life could be found on the
surface they were still aquatic
not so much covered with the caitanya's
hard exoskeleton and they had some new
features for example they had prominent
eyes they had gills they had friends
they had a tail which was not found so
far so that's a major
improvement in characteristic helping
them in their survival as well as eating
as well as finding food
at the same time plants started to
evolve more on the land surfaces on the
landmass moving out from the aquatic
setting and that allowed certain
organisms to grow on those plants and
move out of water so for some particular
amount of amount of style still they had
their hard exoskeletons and these were
the precursors for the insects that we
know today for example the dragonfly
with wingspans of more than one meter of
length and scorpions which grew of up to
1.8 meters that's a ridiculously huge
size for a scorpion and these sort of
organisms started to evolve after this
particular mass extinction event in the
civilian era this was followed by one of
the most amazing periods in the
evolution of life that is known as a
devonian period which spanned from 420
million years ago to 360 million years
ago and as you can see from the fossil
records that plants flourished more
outside water now so we could find
terrestrial plants and terrestrial
flora to
flourish more and that also
helped or made an impact on the life
forms that were existing underneath the
water to move out because now food was
available more on the surface so to
avoid the competition underneath water
they started to move out and you might
also notice that the exoskeleton has now
moved inwards and now it is being
referred to as the endoskeleton or the
skeleton that we know
today like the ones that we have so the
typical amphibian-like or the
reptilian-like skeleton structure was
formed in this particular devonian
period with four
legs
or limbs with five digits that is five
fingers and this was a true amphibian
era where animals could survive both on
land as well as on
as well as underwater
but again when this was happening there
was another mass extinction event that
occurred and this one is speculated to
have
been occurring because of some sort of
natural disaster or climate change
but again it made way for
knife forms to flourish more on the
surface because those few amphibians
which kept out of water onto the land
surface were completely destroyed
whereas the ones which lived inside
water could survive freely now what was
the result or the consequence of this
particular extinction is pretty much
interesting because that was one of the
major reasons why we can survive not
human beings but why so many organisms
could survive on the surface so
that gave rise to the carboniferous
period which existed from 360 to 300
million years ago and as the name
suggests there was more terrestrial life
forms with hard porous scales the true
origin of reptiles and their hard
carbonate rich shell
eggshells which helped them to stay on
the land surface for long without the
requirement to go back to the water for
laying eggs or hatching them they could
survive the dry condition on the surface
and that was a major step in allowing
life forms to evolve on land
this was followed by the permeable
period which existed from 300 to 250
million years ago and this was an
interesting period because here we could
find the first evidences of mammals
these organisms also although they look
quite like dinosaurs they are not
dinosaurs but they can be regarded as a
precursors and synapses where basically
the first mammals
that originated on earth they gave rise
to their own babies without the need to
lay an egg and the babies survived on
their mother's milk as we know from our
elementary levels so
be it a dog or a monkey or even you
this is your first transistor
the name synapses
but then there was again another mass
extinction which is also referred to as
the great time because almost 70 percent
of animal
diet and almost 30 percent of the plants
also got extinct because of this
particular mass extinction event it is
speculated that this happened because of
a massive volcanic eruption on the
surface of earth
but again as on the flip side of the
coin there's always something brighter
to look at the triassic period gave rise
to the most dominant and the most
strongest categories of reptiles that
the earth has ever seen
which are the precursors of dinosaurs
and it was from 250 to 200 million years
ago
so these precursors of dinosaurs could
occupy the entire landmass that was
available because of the mass extinction
event there was hardly any competition
for life pubs to survive and to
have the food that was available so they
could easily flourish and also in some
particularly very small niches
mammals
also survived which were however very
small in size
and then again came another extinction
event the reason is still unclear to
most people that what was what caused
this particular extinction but this
particular extinction wiped off a major
component of those precursors reptiles
whereas the mammals could survive
because they were small and they lived
underneath the rocks somewhere hidden in
a burrow so
this particular mass extinction event
wiped off all other reptiles and made
way for the most ferocious reptiles ever
to have ruled the planet that is a
dinosaurs and ultimately tyrannosaurus
rex to evolve
on earth
so this is the most interesting period
as all you all of you might agree
due to the various movies that have been
done over the years the jurassic and the
cretaceous period together spent more
than 100 million years that
spanning from 200 to 65 million years
ago and in the earlier part that is in
the jurassic park it was more happy for
us a
dinosaurs that ruled and only in the
cretaceous period that it was a period
when we saw the rise of tyrannosaurus
rex
so
this is a very familiar period to most
of you the land forms was filled with
reptiles which were unique
and big and ferocious the dinosaurs
various different species various
different characteristics and also the
flora that is the plants were mostly um
gymnosperms not the angiosperms not the
flowering plants that we see today but
the ones which bore cones and
other fruits so these gymnosperms were
the ones which were mostly found in the
genocide in the cretaceous period and as
of today we have just one living fossil
as we'd like to call it only one species
of gymnosperms surviving on earth and
it's known as ginkgo biloba
but as we all know the dinosaurs did get
extinct because of a massive asteroid
strike as it has been speculated by
various scientists this caused a massive
extinction and wiped off the dinosaurs
completely from the surface of earth
making them extinct forever but
this particular mass extinction event
helped the mammals to actually come out
of their hiding places and to move
freely in the available surface of earth
now because there was no ferocious
competition they could occupy the
various
areas that was present and it helped
them to develop their traits and to
actually
get it actually gave them a better
chance of survival as well as a better
rate of reproduction and therefore this
particular trait of mammals that is
giving rise to their own babies without
the help of an egg was became more and
more dominant and it helped in the
adaptive radiation so from those small
mammals that existed in the dinosaur
dinosaur ruled eight
period
now
gave rise to various different types of
organisms for example the bears or the
koalas
you